[Music]
you are a lifelong gamer uh you love uh
video games and i was curious
if you
have you spent you think more hours uh
playing baseball in your life or these
video games what do you think you've if
you had to is it
i think it's very close yes that's how
intense you are about it yeah but i mean
i had the perfect gaming life i made a
stupid amount of money and i worked once
every five days
you know so i had a lot of free time and
and uh if i wasn't going to be charlie
sheen i was going to stay married to my
wife and do my thing
it was going to be in my room and that's
what i did i played games and and
i had a passion for it my whole life and
and it's one of the reasons i think i'm
still married to my wife of 20 years
shonda who's an amazing woman and um
it's it's how does she feel when you say
that baby i'm with you because of video
games
that's what kept us together but think
about it my career kind of paralleled
the rise of sports media it's 24 7.
right now somebody clicks an iphone
photo of you in a hotel with someone
you're not supposed to be with and it's
on youtube in five minutes and hey
you're talking to me i know how it works
and married over my skis all those
things um but but uh it's it's it's
something that i've always done and i
had a passion for it and so when i
thought about retiring and walking away
from the game this just seemed like the
natural next thing for me to try and do
i'm curious you uh went to uh iraq to
visit the troops and while you were
there you uh you played you okay so yeah
video games it's the same story ever
right so i'm in iraq for 10 days
visiting our troops and they're amazing
and they're uh out on patrol i mean
they're in they're on combat patrol they
come back to their forward operating
base and 10 guys get on to xbox live
arcade and start playing call of duty
together
and they're online these tenants these
are these are a trained
military and they're online they're
playing live xbox live as a 10 man team
against like 15 year old kids back home
and they're waxing a minute
it was oh it was unbelievable it was
awesome i was like wow they're just
laying down fire and it's like yeah the
soapy 247 is actually like a squad
commander of a special elite forces unit
and he's just waxing like 16 year olds
yeah he's amazing these poor kids are at
home just crying what happened
and they're talking trash doing it which
made it that much funner uh let's get to
this kingdoms of amalur yes reckoning uh
this is a this is a fantastic game and
you've got some really uh big talents
behind this yeah todd mcfarlane ari
salvatore i think lord of the rings kind
of middle earth high fantasy um it's a
it's a it's a franchise that this is our
first game coming out and we actually we
brought some footage for for us yes yes
i was gonna show this is the game and uh
and and you brought footage this is a uh
simulation of the game so this is this
is part of the game we actually did a
little localized version for the irish
american gamers in in tribute to you uh
in the new england gamers out there and
and we found a way to actually create
some content with you in the game so
you've you've put me into the game you
are in the game am i gonna be pleased
with this i think you're gonna be
ecstatic it's you and i in the game
actually so this is something that we
made for for you and for your your fans
okay let's see how i do against uh curt
schilling in uh reckoning let's take a
look
if a fight is what you desire
you'll find me quite hard to kill
unfortunately i cannot say the same for
you
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all you people are supposed to
have my back
and you have not had my back tonight and
you
i'm this tiny little yeah and i'm
scottish for some reason
the whole part of it is the fact that
you're talking trash on me at the
beginning of that and i'm beating you
down at the end of that
[Laughter]